community brighton 8 news now is
sponsored by our community pride
partners finley automotive group
southwest medical part of optum care and
silver state schools credit union
the holidays can be difficult on
families rocky checked in with southwest
medical the sponsors of this next
segment to get tips on dealing with
depression this time of the year
we are excited to celebrate the holidays
usually a very joyous time but
especially nowadays a lot of people are
dealing with you know holiday depression
um we suffered a lot of loss and
obviously mental health issues so let's
just talk about what that means for
communities
absolutely rocky you know the holiday
season is a very festive and joyous time
for so many but it can also carry some
stress and anxiety including feelings of
depression and that's not surprising
it's such a busy time of year between
preparing cooking cleaning shopping
entertaining and all of those things
going on in addition to the pandemic and
the stress of the economy that can only
worsen those feelings
absolutely so what are the signs that we
should look out for for ourselves and
for the people that we love
signs and symptoms of depression though
they may only occur once in your life
are likely to be repetitive as well and
those can include sleep disturbances
loss of interest in your normal daily
activities feeling of guilt or
worthlessness low energy or fatigue
difficulty focusing or concentrating
changes in appetite including weight
gain
different types of physical symptoms
like headaches or stomach pain
and any just general feelings of feeling
down or depressed
this is such an important topic for for
especially now um when should people
seek help when they're feeling this way
or when they know someone else is
feeling this way
if anyone feels or sees these signs or
symptoms within themselves or somebody
they care about it's so important to
speak to them and help guide them to
connect with a local healthcare provider
and when would you consider it an
emergency
for someone
if you or someone you know is
considering inflicting self-harm or
harming anyone else it's important to
connect them with local health
authorities or even contact the national
suicide prevention hotline it's
important to know if somebody's in
danger that they have that support
certainly if somebody is in imminent
danger calling 9-1-1 and staying with
them or if you feel the ability to
safely get them to an emergency room
that would be the best thing to do
that's a great reminder and if someone
is not in crisis in a crisis or is not
at that level um what should they do to
cope with their feelings
recognizing the triggers the things that
bring on those feelings is important to
help combat those before they get worse
some positive thinking and planning can
help mitigate that
acknowledging your feelings is so
important if you've experienced loss
it's important to know that feelings of
sadness or grief are okay it's okay to
feel guilty or sad it's okay to cry and
expressing your holiday feelings is
important and can i add one
absolutely learn to say no i think
that's so important for everyday life
even beyond the holidays just learn to
say no don't don't overdo don't overdo
it
i agree with that saying
saying yes when you should say no can
only lead to worsening of resentment and
feeling overwhelmed absolutely so doctor
goku what should people do if they're
seeking help should they reach out
most definitely if you or someone you
know is feeling signs or symptoms of
depression sadness or loneliness please
reach out to your primary care physician
or a health care provider they are here
for you we are all here for you
thank you again to southwest medical
associates for being one of our
community pride partners las vegas